there's no such thing as winning
business it doesn't exist right but when
we listen to the language of so many of
our leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't always know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one being the best or beating
their competition
based on what
based on what agreed upon time frames
metrics and objectives and this is a
problem because when we play with a
finite mindset in an infinite game when
we play to win in a game that has no
Finish Line there are actually some very
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big one being the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation and the decline
of innovation and so we actually have to
adjust our mindset to fit the game that
we're playing and in the case of cyber
security you know you're you're actually
trying to prevent crime from happening
the criminals aren't trying to beat you
they're trying to do more they're just
trying to get more money they're just
trying to trick people they just want
access they actually don't care about
you and your cyber security they're just
trying to do more crime right it's an
infinite game
and you don't even know who all the
criminals are there's no such thing as
winning cyber security it doesn't exist
it's an ongoing Cat and Mouse game and
so you have to have the right mindset
for the game you're playing and in this
case it's not about winning it's about
constant Improvement then it goes back
to that analogy that we discussed right
at the beginning when we talked about
the lifestyle of business versus trying
to treat it like a finite game right
which is it's not the end of the the
financial year doesn't symbolize the end
of the game it's just a marker it's just
a waypoint and so all of these things
that you and I have been discussing is
all about constant Improvement you'll
never be perfect at any of it ever
that's not the point the point is that
you're constantly working to advance and
you're constantly saying how can we be
better how can we be better relative not
only to our to the other players in the
game but also relative to the criminals
in the game because you could be the
best quote-unquote uh compared to all of
all of your uh of the other companies in
the marketplace but if the criminals are
smarter than you then then there's no
point yeah
um so so I think that's that's to adjust
our mindset to play for the game we're
in which is the game of business and
especially cyber security which really
is an infinite game
um I think it's really really important